abone ol
bu
bilimleri ulaştığı evlilik hırsızlığı
meselesi artık
yaşamamış
yaşamış yaptınız
yoksa şöyle söyleyebilirim kız öğrenci
kendi özelliklerini Hayır
yaşamın anlamını yüzünden soralım
konuşmazdım hiç
dinleme çok bozuk değil yaşam geldim yok
o yüzden bizim için anlamlı var
Yazık
Bize
özelliği maşallah
bu muhabbetten çıkarak pişmeye başladı
aslında bu yüzden geç bu farklı
kesimlerinden insanlarla iletişim
bir yapışıklık sene kadar önce iyi
yazdım
bilmiyorum dışarıda görüşürüz
Biz o
ne yapacağız böyle yaşamındaki anlamı
olmadı mı öyle mi Sen elindeki buluşalım
diye sor
bu İsyan olduğunu düşündüm Aslında genç
başka olarak Altın Bilgi vereceğiz Ahmet
kadar
ders
yapmıyoruz
O
söyler
misiniz hayatım
sadece bu sorunun anlamlı bir soru oldu
kalmış Ben de konuşmada 3.16 ilk
öncelikle giriş soruyu sormalı yanıtsız
bir olsun hangisinin anlamlı bir giriş
oldu yapacağım ikisine
İslam baktığımızda
dayanabilir misin yoksa nasıl Oğlum
burada maması öndeki gideceğiz
değilse yine yapmasın olarak nasıl yere
bir
işaret edilir
var mı
Bir
varmış
insanlar doğası gereği anlamlandırmak
isterler
iyi az gibi
birşey
arkasında yazan ikişer başladığımız var
anlamak istiyorum ve anlamlı olsun
olursa bu sizden etkinlikler yine kaydım
yaşınıza ya da kullandığınız yani
bakacağım
ama bir şeyi sağlaması geldi abi olur
burada bir şekilde gebelik Yaşıyor musun
ya
abone ol ve
[Müzik]
yaşamın adından söz ettik bu tarz
ikinciden mevlamız
[Müzik]
olur Allah'ın
olmadığınız iyi acaba Sorulur kendisi
yazıyor Ben
değil hayır olmasın
onun
dişlerden biri olacağım bu açıdan kendi
sisteminizi yeniden
yüklemek olarak sana çünkü bakıldığında
bazen sorularımıza cevap vermediniz Bu
bir soru yanlış sorulmuş bak
ve
yaşamın anlamı gibi kocaman
yıldır
olduğumuzu varsayım suyu vermiş sonra
bakalım bakalım yine belki ama az kaldı
mı
yaşamın anlamı değil
içinden çıkılmaz bir hal dediniz
iyi kaçınılmaz olarak
almıyor Ağlama mesajınız
ama ne kadar kullanıyoruz ama kavramının
anlamı değil
anlamı anlamı
nasıl yapabileceksiniz
bu
Ama her zaman
aslında Özge'ye özellik kendisinin ona
girdi gösteririz kilit Bir ilişkide var
sizin kendinize gösterdiğiniz şey Biz de
doğru yani burçlar bakıldığında Özge'nin
kendisinde ya da bizden bağımsız olarak
bugün kendisine alalım
olunca anlam
anlamı yaratan sen o yüzden
yeter
Beşiktaş
zamanda Barış'ın
anlamı da o hangi binalarda
kullandığımızda görebilir Ne oldu yine
bu
işlerde farklı alanlarda İşte başladı
anlam daima işi tekrar ediyorum
olduğunu görüyorsunuz Bir vermedim
vermem
Şimdi bir
araya gelmesin ya
[Müzik]
da olsa malzeme de yazmaz
malzemeden fazlası bu açıdan kapının
çıplaklığını şair
olmak
Aslında büyük bir malzeme değil
güzel şeyden varmış sağlamıştır ben bu
işi o malzemeyi bir şekilde kullanacağım
onu çektireceğim Vallahi
buldum ve bu işi öylesine gireceğim
öylesine Biz var bu ismi Paris Elsa
sadece
günlük hayatımızda kullandığımız
mı salak gibi
Hatta yine başladı varız ya
bu hesap Bu iyi açıldı büyüklükte bir
yol açabilir Çünkü aslında gündelik
alanda bizim şiiri anlamlandırmak için
ya da bu
bu şekilde Kullanmış olduğumuz sınavları
Evrensel zaman üstü mutlaka vardır
gerçekmiş Allah mutlak değildir ama iyi
özellikle Özlem isteriz ilgili bir
şeymiş
şimdi bu bizim evin
gösterdim alanlarda konuşma meseleler
isteriz
Bu
anlamda bir şey
nasıl gideceğimi söyledim Neden
gösterdim nedensiz hiç bir Geldim
geldim olur araba bizim kullanıldı
ablamın
anlamın mutlak olmuş
öyle arıyoruz ki
anlama dediğiniz şeyi
cevabım hiç lan Çok mu
Bir yaşındaki anlamıyorsanız olur Çünkü
anla olan bir şey değil yaratılan
kurulan bir şeydir bu
da
olabilir biz neden şu sefer bastığımızda
istediğimizde Ebu karşılaşıyor yalnız
Oğlum biz geçmişi
haksız takvimi iletişim
Şakir'in şarkısı tarihi değil bu sözden
anlamam üzerinde uzlaştığı gösterdiğim
güzel olmaz yaşamda özlemle da böyle
olmazdı Allah bulduğunuz bir şey
söyleyeyim mi çağırsam uğraşan çok
sevdiğim var
de
iyiyim şeyleri Allah'ını için izin
şeylere verdi ama aslında o iyi bir o
özellikle ekranda gördüğünüz Su sanatçı
Makro gibi sanatçı hesabımızı şimdi bak
var
Eğer bir
vahşet
taş
[Müzik]
başka şeyler de
yapabilirsiniz
O yüzden başlayacağım yürü len Aslında
görebiliyorsunuz yaşamı anlamsızlığı ve
ama dolması yaşamın kendisinden
olduğundan sınav yaşayalım bir şey demiş
ki videomuzda varmış yaşam onunla Ne
yapıyorsunuz olur
şişlerde görmesin bu
içerisinde yani olan yapıyorsunuz
bozulur
bu İzmit içindeler son bunu İnsanlık
tarihi boyunca
oldu mu Evet hep söyleyemeyiz özellikle
tanrının ürünü teması ile birlikte
başlayan
başladığımız
gösterdim
Çünkü bir tane böyle bildiğiniz
yeşil de amacın efsane
ismi ol
eş anlamlısı başladı
ama ben
bir
şeyler var şimdi ediyorum
yeni bir Allah olalım
ulaşabileceğimiz varmış anlamlarını yeni
olaraktan Fera
yani gibi ağrılar
başlar içimde
Bence
yazmak Yani bir şeyi anlama geldiği için
[Müzik]
ihtiyaç dökülen eşek geldim
bir şeyler bulurum bizim için ne anlama
geldi
Çağdaş oyuncular bir ihtiyacımız var
Çünkü yaşam o
zaman dedim söylemiş
bağlı
olması aslında o şey de bir şey de var
olmanızı sağlık
yaşamış yaşamış olduğu çıkmış buna
girdiğimizde İnşallah alıyoruz
bir şey geldiniz
Ben
başlangıçta olan kimyasal sonrasında
dışarıda bitkisel bir bakın
ama bu
ya Bak böyle bir saniye sağlıklı yaşamın
anlamı uğraşamayacağım
bu dünyanın zamansal geliyor gibi takdir
video dünyanın zaman Sağlığı iyi zamanın
benim içinde olduğu sorusu anlamış Çünkü
ben zaman kalmış şimdi bak zamanın için
anlamadı sonunda
bu sandviç ya
yaşayamam ki bir anlamı olduğunu bilmiş
geçersek yaşam mı oluruz bu ettiğim şey
şu eğer bir araya gelmiş
olacak
iyi
[Müzik]
sadece kendimize bu yaşandı bu yaşamı
anlamlı bir şey farklı olarak daha fazla
anladılar yarattığınız
bir ve ötekinin karşı insan doğa insan
hayvan ve toplumsal ayrımların oradan
bir
varlık canlı ordusu olarak kırmızı
gerektiren bir bu şekilde olduğun için
de
var
itibaren yaşamın anlamını dair
bulacaklar biz yaratmaz bu göre de
bahsettiğim gibi başka boncuklar olarak
babam felsefecilere sanatçılara Takip
ettiğim sihirli gelen
kişiler yaparız nedir
vermeyecekler ama
nasıl olur herkes habersiz
onlardan aldırmış böyle bir insanı
anlamak
için ne anlama geldiğini bir şekilde
çeviriyorum ol çok az kaldı mı Oruç
aldım sonraki bir yorumlarınız için
ne
yapıyoruz
bilimsel bulgular her zaman var ya da
etkileyici bir şekilde aldık
Nedenmiş o
kadar çok gerekli olan şey yapmıyoruz
doğru bir doğru öğreneceğiz
her zaman doğru bilgiye sahip olur mu
ellerimizin sağladım bu dosyada Çağdaş
felsefe ki En azından bir
Bu
bir şekilde çalışabiliriz
mutlaka seni kaldım kendisini içkiye
olmuş bakarsanız Okulistik
sevgilisi olduğunu da yanımda
canımız yiyelim işte olmak demek çok
bilgili olmak demek Çünkü çok büyük olan
sizin iyice var mı gitmez burada
şöyledir iyi değildir eğlendir bilgelik
bilgiyi kullanma mı bunu söylemek olacak
ama
oldu sonunda öğrenci çizgiye
[Müzik]
değiştireceksin bu
biliriz
olursa kucağınıza var mı Ne oldu kalmış
yeni içerisinde zaten eğleneceğim bir
şey değildir
bir
sonraki ikinci boşalma yapacağız
o zaman ararsın
Sağ
ol Allah mı dersiniz Ben ev yıllarda hep
o kahramanı düşünüyorum
hatta kendisi ve doktor vardır o da uzun
yollara Baş
ve
sonrasında hayatın hiçbir anlamı
olmadığını
anlatıyor bu
birşeydir
diye bildiler bağırsak
seyahatlerinin İstanbul noktasında
açılır
şöyle
bir
yaşam hiçbir kutsal olmayabilir ama
toprağımızı ekip için değildir yaşamı
anlamlı hale getirdiniz
indirilebilir Jim